the swifties aren't messing around a
group of Die Hard Taylor Swift fans are
suing Ticket Masters parent company for
fraud that happening after they got
screwed out of concert tickets for the
songbirds upcoming tour the website
crashed which allowed scalpers to scoop
up tickets and then sell them in
astronomical prices with some going for
20 grand now Taylor's fans are out for
blood accusing Ticketmaster of unlawful
conduct and violating any trust laws the
doj is also looking into what happened
Greg I'm glad the Department of Justice
is looking into this yeah well okay
let's just get this is a difficult topic
for me and you guys know that I feel
given my past history with Taylor and I
wish her the best I think I should
recuse myself from commenting on the
specific case because the feelings are
still kind of raw between us and we may
have an agreement that we weren't going
to talk about each other so let me talk
about in general the the uh the ticket
situation there has to be a simpler way
of seeing live acts it's super confusing
there's a lot of scalping it's so
complicated so it leads me to this
question when is Amazon gonna have a
button that says live ax a place just
like it has for books and movies and
stuff and you go on there and you just
go to live acts it shows you everywhere
in the country and it's like and you can
choose a seat and it can be different in
price just like the difference in the
size of a product that seems to me the
solution Amazon is buying up everything
buy up Ticketmaster just take over this
business and make it so that you can
just press a button and go I'm going to
see Morrissey in LA in July 2023. great
broke up with who again you and Taylor
it's a long story we look we both kind
of grew apart and that's what happens
when somebody like me is more successful
like when you were two successful people
and somebody moves on it was a lot for
her it's a lot you still talk to her
right now you had a mixed match of
ambition yeah you really succeeded yeah
I just can't settle down I'm a rambling
man Dana you are Rambling On and On
so you might I don't know if you guys
remember this Ticketmaster that when
they merged with Live Nation that was a
big deal back when kind of in the in the
business press right and something like
AOC she says that they should never have
been allowed to do this I don't know why
she cares so much maybe it was because
she foresaw this problem but the other
thing I was thinking is that
Ticketmaster weighed in on the Georgia
election law like a lot of companies did
and it was bizarre like why are you
weighing in on this right so I have a
feeling that when the when they get
called up to Capitol Hill there's going
to be a lot of people from both sides
that are going to want to talk to them
I'm also surprised that Taylor herself
has said nothing
that's so Taylor
comes to surprise you but every
fans and to her but she has yet to say
anything
so when we talked about this a couple
weeks ago we were discussing the fact
that if someone was going
to end up having a big effect on the way
the industry worked it was going to be
Taylor Swift doing this right that she
has always been on the side of her fans
of the artists Etc and I know this is a
couple dozen plaintiffs and I'm sure the
judge has something to say about the
odds of them actually winning this case
but it will shine light on something
that is wildly unfair that Ticketmaster
first of all it was portrayed that if
you signed up to be one of these VIPs
that you would have Early Access to this
and these people didn't know of course
the Ticketmaster had gone and already
bought up these tickets to put it on the
resale market and hiked up the prices at
this level and one of the things that is
different about a Taylor Swift tour is
Greg knows from just a regular tour is
she needs the largest Arenas everywhere
that she can't just go and do a small
concert right for 15 people or whatever
it is she has she would love to but she
can't she could no and I understand that
yeah
she could do a private yes yeah thing
for us her heart is so big
the biggest
um so I imagine that something will
happen from this just because she has
such a a great track record in terms of
shaking up the industry and shaking it
off yeah so shake it off that's good
that was one of her talents yes really
no what
what she shook it off the breakup he
made it yeah yeah yeah okay is it my
turn to a question or I just start
rambling
uh okay here's the thing 26 fans are
suing okay they're suing for breach a
contract intentional misrepresentation
fraud fraudulent inducement Anti-Trust
violations here's the bottom line when
Live Nation uh and and uh Ticketmaster
joined and the federal government let it
join the federal government pretty much
relied on the a promise that the
companies would refrain from taking full
advantage of quote their power the
government needs to stop asking these
parties for promises and just maintain
competition this thing is more even more
complicated by the fact that there were
verified fans who were paying for
something they don't know what they were
paying for but they thought that it was
for early sales and the truth is whether
it's Bots or whether it's scalpers they
were already sold out but Ticketmaster
has a bit of a defense saying if they if
they could have sold the number of
tickets that were wanted she would have
had to have had 900 concerts to more
than 20 times what she planned the
woman's a superstar this is one once in
a lifetime situations all right and
having said that there's there's just
one more thing that I want to say the
court has not yet accepted this petition
who knows if it's even going anywhere
and that's the end of it that is the end
of it thank God I wonder Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now